les rosaces de notre dame de paris n'ont
pas disparu dans les flammes mais des
vitraux ont pu être touchés
pour claire babey maître verrier
spécialisé dans la restauration
il est trop tôt pour faire un état des
lieux mais le pire n'est a priori pas
arriver grâce au plomb qui s'est
rassemblé les vitraux les plombs ont
peut-être été fragilisées ou ont
peut-être fondu par endroits mais en
l'occurrence si les vitraux sont restés
en place c'est que le réseau ton a quand
même fait son travail pour maintenir les
verts donc c'est absolument impossible
maintenant de dire ce qui a été
réellement affecté sur ses vitraux l'un
du simple encrassement à la suit au
verre cassé par le choc thermique
l'éventail des dégâts provoqués par un
incendie peut être très large dans ces
situations la première étape est de
toutes examinées
il ya en général un diagnostic avant
qu'on intervienne dans leurs instituts
ensuite quand on dépose les vitraux on
les examine un parent en atelier et
c'est là qu'on va déterminer si les
plombs sont fragilisés si les verts sont
cassés c'est là que des maîtres verriers
comme claire babel son équipe
interviennent il restaure actuellement
un panneau du 16e siècle qui provient de
l'église saint merri à paris il essaye
de conserver le maximum d'éléments
d'origine il était vraiment très très
fragmenté donc là on était obligé de
d'enlever le plomb qui datait du 20e
siècle et on recolle chaque petit
fragment d'origine on reconstitue les
pièces sont faites avec des collages ils
peuvent aussi remplacer les morceaux de
verre disparus qu'ils peignent est serti
de cuivre pour les différencier des
pièces d'origine
un savoir faire qui aidera s'il le faut
à redonner toute leur majesté aux
vitraux de notre dame